good afternoon LinkedIn how's everybody
doing today all right good afternoon
happy Thursday and welcome to the New
York City local edition of LinkedIn
speaker series out of curiosity how many
of you have attended a local edition
speaker series before fantastic look at
all those hands will fantastic so for
those of you who are brand new to the
program or joining over the stream the
New York City local edition is an
extension of our LinkedIn global speaker
series program which is basically the
whole point is to take all these local
rockstars that exist in New York City
bring them into our office to inspire
and form us spark conversations start
connections and really just make sure
that we're being informed about all the
different things that are new next note
or the across different industries and
fields so so excited to have you all
today and even more excited to introduce
you to our phenomenal guests gary
vaynerchuk so how many of you had the
chance to see hear or read about gary in
the news at some point almost everyone's
hands fantastic so I personally and
what's above like 70% of the room will
just round up but super excited to
welcome Gary so for those of you who
don't know and many of you do know Gary
is the internet famous social guru and
builder of businesses famous for
everything from lemonade to selling wine
has his very own digital media agency
vaynermedia which he runs with his
brother since 2009 which has had great
success he is the definition of an
entrepreneur with total hustle so very
excited to welcome him to really inform
and inspire us share what's new what's
next what's noteworthy within his space
and he's going to be joined by our very
own chip cutter one of our senior
editors here at LinkedIn so with that
help me give a warm LinkedIn welcome to
Gary as well as chip come on up guys all
righty so I'm going to hand it over to
chip as well as Gary but with that know
that of course we want you to be social
throughout this experience so you can
talk to Gary via his handle at Gary Vee
Vee or using our hashtag and speaker so
have fun get social and gentlemen can
they just raise their hand
yeah they can do that to go do it online
offline the whole thing all right with
that
here chip thank you be great we're gonna
keep this really casual
going to talk for a little bit then we
want to get make sure we have plenty of
time for QA thrilled Gary's here so as
you all know we have this tradition here
where we asked guest speakers to tell us
or ideally show us something that's not
on their LinkedIn profile so so Gary
what's your what's your secret Talent my
secret on your special what's not on
your LinkedIn profile that we should
know about uh what's not in on my
LinkedIn profile is I once judged the
Miss America contest two years ago I've
been thinking about putting that on my
LinkedIn actually so that was kind of
weird that was special talent oh I can I
can do this with my tongue it's about
all I got hey that's perfect that's
great I'm pretty one-dimensional luckily
that thing makes money so I've been able
to survive but but I mean so tell me
about that I mean so you you hosted Miss
America you you I don't you've developed
a wine business from from you know this
into this huge kind of online juggernaut
you've you're now working at this
digital agency you've got a ten book
deal with Harper how do you kind of
think about your career how do you get
to how did you get to this point well I
think you know and this is just the
truth when I look up there and I see
guru it makes me want to stab myself in
the neck
I know where I'm at as somebody who
talks a lot and I understand why it
happens and it has a lot to do with just
my overall DNA and I know how I
communicate and what my shtick is but I
take a lot of pride in the fact that I
was thirty years old before I ever even
popped up my head to the world and had
already built a 40 million dollar a year
business by just being an operator right
so I think that I take a lot of pride
that my digital agency has gone from
three to a hundred million dollars in
revenue in four years and that's been on
execution that's not because I'm funny
or I have a lot of Twitter followers
that's because the biggest brains of the
world and decided we do a better job
than droga or widening Kennedy or 360 I
like I mean I'm a business I think of
myself as a businessman who happens to
have a personality that because his mom
gave him so many compliments as a kid
he's desperate for compliments from
others and so he has to put himself out
there to had to have scale in admiration
so
it's just the truth right like that just
like luckily I also have self-awareness
so I can say that but like to me
probably the most fun that I have in my
career is that I know probably half of
you and any of your friends and 80% of
America when they first see a video in a
Facebook feed or read it
influence your post or watch me on
YouTube or see me at a public event
literally think that I'm a [ __ ]
snake oil salesman I'm not confused
that that's kind of six seven out of
tens people's first reaction there's a
digital there's a very dirty little
secret about that spiel though is when
you actually have the chops you start
getting double credit for not being full
of [ __ ] and so I actually think I get
more credit for my business
accomplishments because nobody thought
that that's what I was actually doing
and so that's kind of a funny thing well
and your your your personality your
brand is so much a part of your
company's brand and everything else too
I mean so how have you how have you
thought about that I mean we're right
now we're being filmed by your daily
video show do you rock d-roc is back
there or dailyvee so how do you think
about all that of you're kind of
building you up your own personal brand
everything else there too you'll have
different levers right like I did
basically here's what I do for a living
I day trade attention so what I do for a
living is I day trade end user attention
that's how I launched an e-commerce
website in 1996 even though that I had
no tech skills and really even knew what
the hell I was doing the only thing I
knew was that when people were gonna buy
things on the Internet and that was not
something you're all youngsters like a
lot of you don't remember this that was
highly debated the Internet itself was a
debated thing and so that was the
macro-level
and then basically email newsletter and
Google AdWords and YouTube content and
Twitter and Facebook and LinkedIn
content has out you know you said to me
earlier you were so nice when I first
reached out you were in right away I was
laughing because I was like of course
you had one of the biggest platforms in
the world around the context of business
I want to be there in that space to me
that was the easiest yes of my life well
I remember it was like a Friday
afternoon I called you up we were
talking about the influencer program we
first launched this you were I think I
got like two sentences out you're like
I'm in I do this all the time
No
spamming him I was like I was like 100%
and so the reason the you know to me
I've been watching snapchat for three
years and only in January did I start
getting really loud of like this is
gonna work to me there is no doubt that
snapchat is at scale and we'll be at
scale for mainstream because there's a
network effect at a certain scale and so
I am very good intuition on what
everybody in this room is going to do a
lot of times before they even realize
they're gonna do it that's my core thing
that's what I've got and now I'm trying
to scale it and the reason I decided to
hide it my career to take a step back
and eat [ __ ] and build a client service
business was because I needed to scale
the one thing I had and that's not what
I have now I have a 600 person for
office 100 million dollar revenue
business that scale is my capability as
a human to understand really had a day
trade attention and know when
something's overpriced or under priced
and know how to not be a headline reader
in the world of social media 24 months
ago when everybody was crying about
Facebook organic reach and Wow
they pulled the rug from underneath us
and this is so bad and don't do it
anymore I knew as a practitioner that
the best ad product that I've seen since
early Google AdWords was being built and
so and then I became a practitioner in
it I'm a practitioner in snapchat the
reason I do snapchat stories I want to
be a practitioner YouTube was something
I was on so early that I took it for
granted and I realized I had to get my
game back on and so that's why I do
content because I'm learning through my
own consecration and then I have my own
like spiel the reason I do daily be is
because I spew a lot about hustle and I
realize crap I don't think people really
realize that I am fundamentally out
working everybody so basically this is
just propaganda to stick it to everybody
that I work harder than that hey you can
see we watch you all day long what
you're doing everything else - yep let's
go back to this idea of like trading the
attention though and snapchat what was
the moment when they told you okay
snapchat is the real deal this is
something we got to kind attention more
attention to I mean very very very early
on there you know I also enjoy the other
thing about being good at this is you
get the i-told-you-so moments right like
I love the clip when I was on with Piers
Morgan saying that Facebook stole
Instagram for a billion dollars which
led to 10,000 tweets that I was an idiot
because a lot of you remember was only
500 days that Instagram was in business
and
like a billion it's crazy that it wasn't
that long ago but a billion for that
seemed like outer space and the same
thing would snapchat I've been on
snapchat very aggressively since 2013
what got me to pay attention or the
moment was tens of millions of people
were using it like this is like the
funniest thing like nothing bothers me
more than when people set first guru but
ii ii is futurist or disruptor right you
know to me I think I'm the most
practical operator and marketer in the
world I just mark it for the day we
actually live in right now not yesterday
not tomorrow
so do I know VR or after school or
musically are emerging and things will
happen of course but do I think it's the
best use of every dollar and hour right
now no I do not and so I that's what I
do so I watch snapchat every day and
then 9 10 months ago I'm like okay this
is really hitting critical mass and then
when I watched the first week of what
was happening with dj khaled I was like
okay this is millions
this is millions of people watching this
this isn't the tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands that I thought
people were getting from snapchat this
is three million I got a screenshot from
it like three million people I'm like
okay this is now a real true meaningful
scale which means it's not just 13 to 18
and then I just live life right like I
travel so much I started seeing 30 and
40 year old people with a yellow app on
their home screen right like it was
really that basic and then there's the
thing that blows my mind which is
everybody this room can do what I do
which is wake up in the morning and the
first thing I do grab their phone look
at the App Store top 103 apps and look
at the charts it's just been sitting
there in the top five for [ __ ] I
don't know a year and a half like that's
real data like I'm like there's no guest
I'm not I'm not predicting musically
success it's been a top 20 app for four
and a half months like it's like this is
just very basic yeah
so so and then so for people in this
room then too and everything how should
I mean you were quoted in a Wired story
saying snapchats about to have its mom
moment right where it just crosses
generations and everything else - how
should marketers and sales people and
everybody else that's in this room how
should they be thinking about it and
well I mean look I mean you know you
said ahead of time there's a lot of
salespeople here and I'm like cool
I'm a Salesman like that's like that's
all I do all this stuff or so in a b2b
environment you know you just got to
think about what what works for example
I think Sports Center marketing
television 1988 292 is really
interesting what do I mean by that
ESPN knew that Fox and CNN were coming
and we're gonna have competitive sports
networks so they knew that anybody could
cover Jordan and Griffey and Gretzky so
what they did was they started story
telling about their newscasters they
made their employees the item I think
one of the best lengthens business could
be better if LinkedIn's
snapchat account right now was actually
you guys doing your version of the
office and building the personal like
just going around and doing that because
then that's going to make you more human
and any of the 23 to 30 year old
decision makers of 2017 in a b2b space
are gonna feel a bigger connection to
you if they're a nerd funnel if you're
putting out that kind of content now
that sounds silly that's not like that's
not the common thing that people are
thinking about but these are the things
I look at because I look at history to
repeat itself quite a bit you know I
think pattern recognition is extremely
important in what we're living through
now because the Internet itself is
really changing the game and we're still
just in a very guys we're only 20 years
into this like I know it's been around
longer but I mean normal people started
going in 95 you know and so it's still
very very very early and so for me they
should be thinking about a does the
person they're trying to get to actually
spend time and attention on that
probably not but I would say in 2017 and
18 it does and if they want to use that
you know it's like running a marathon if
you're not training for it you get
caught a lot of companies have the
audacity by not doing this stuff that
they'll just throw money at it but then
you don't have the cadence and you don't
have the context and you struggle with
the transition and you miss your opening
so I do a lot of early behavior stuff
not for the ROI of the moment but 18 24
months
I'm very I've done well with Instagram
video or snapchat because I learned a
lot back on social cam if you guys
remember that that was hot for I don't
know eight seconds but it was very hot
because the newsfeed on Facebook big dit
that millions of users wasn't good
enough product to have the long-standing
but I learned a lot about 10-second
video production in a mobile environment
that I then deployed against vine which
was very successful REE that I'm now
deploying against snapchat and while
we're on video I mean what do you think
of of meerkat and periscope and
everything too are you so focused on
those or no I love live streaming I
think I think we've all seen this it's
hard to be good at live so I think right
now there's a lot of crap on it but I
think it's a very big medium I think
anything that happens in real life will
happen in our world and so live
television is real and so I do think
like I could see eSports and the gaming
leagues doing really well with stuff
like that or some sport that doesn't
exist right now using that as their live
mechanism to the world you know I'm an
early investor in meerkat but I'm
spending all my time in periscope and
Facebook because I need to be
historically right not my investments be
successful so that's how I'm thinking
about that landscape right now I also
say another thing for all salespeople
here I came from B to C right I tried to
get any person in America that drank
wine to buy for me I've now been in b2b
I think b2b marketing is the best I love
it when you actually know the name of
the human being that you're trying to
get to this is the holy grail that I've
been expecting from you guys my great
disappointment personally with this
company outside of all the things that I
love is I just want a better ad product
that lets me I mean the fact that I can
target people against their job
description or things like the dream
that I had three years ago when I was in
the office here that I thought was
coming soon it's still not here is when
somebody changes a job I wanted to run
Wine Library champagne congratulation
ads but I want it to be more see the
thing is it's got to be seamless and
they have to consume it but these are
the things that I think about right hey
where's the attention clearly you've got
the b2b attention the problem is it's
used too much as a utility then you guys
came along and I was like yes this is
what's going to happen now I just need
the ad integration to be stronger and I
would spend a boatload of money on a
platform like this or any other platform
that has people's attention especially
when I understand the psychology of that
person on the platform if I'm trying to
sell to a 42 year old woman executive
what I would put in front of her content
wise on Facebook Pinterest and LinkedIn
would be substantially different because
of the psychology of her when she's in
that stream
and so the reason I wrote Jab Jab Jab
right hook my last book was because we
are not spending enough time
understanding that these social networks
they are not distribution channels
they're actually places you should tell
stories you just have to understand the
context just like old-school TV what you
put on at 11:00 p.m. at night on NBC is
different than when you put on at 3:00
p.m. and so those are the things that I
spend a lot of time on the psychology of
the end user got it so I want to get
into you know one of the things that you
do you're running a venture capitalist
now you have a your you have a seed fund
you're doing you're raising another
another round with that um what are you
looking at right now what interests you
where are you looking kind of trend wise
the next 12 to 18 months I'm very hard
on eSports I think that twitch reminds
me a lot of MySpace let me explain not
that they're similar or have similar
outcomes when myspace sold a lot of the
BC people kind of said well that was the
big social media exit and they kind of
got lazy to understand it was the first
inning not the end
and I think twitches billion dollar exit
has a lot of people saying well that's
that and I think eSports is just
starting I mean when I think about where
eSports is 15 years from now more people
are watching the eSports World
Championship match of the biggest game
of the moment then are going to watch
everything but probably the Superbowl so
I want to ride that trend so I'm paying
attention to that I'm obsessed with VR
and I mean obsessed but I'm obsessed the
way I was about the Internet itself in
1994 what I mean by that is we're much
further away from VR being real consumer
than people realize all the people that
look like me all the [ __ ] gurus we're
going to all say it's here it's not here
but what is here is getting into the
pitches and the forks the infrastructure
there'll be a lot of money to be made if
you can buy the companies that you know
the big companies of the world are gonna
have to buy to be successful VR sound is
something I'm paying attention stuff
like that so I'm very bullish VR is the
first thing that's come along in society
that reminds me of the Internet itself
and I think it will fundamentally change
all of our lives 20 years from now
including things like tourism think
about a world everybody's worried very
young in here think about a world in 20
years when you're wearing contact lenses
not this [ __ ] oculus [ __ ] contact
lenses and your brain is 98.6%
in bill
of what you're seeing and you're looking
at the Eiffel Tower it's interesting I
mean if you're getting that far along in
your brain believing it like I don't
know what none of us know what that one
41.4 looks like and I don't know if that
data is right that's being spewed but I
can tell you that everything in our
society has to be rethought
if we really believe we're somewhere or
with someone and definitely the movie
industry and the gaming video game
industry like are clearly going to be
disrupted in those are huge industries
so I'm very excited about that space and
then honestly I'm just in the jockey
business right if I find an entrepreneur
that I really believe in that has the
ability to pivot three or four times and
figure it out I'm always looking for
that girl that guy because they win they
just adjust they know how to manage
their burn I think we just lived through
the greatest year of fake entrepreneurs
you know for the last five years
what I mean by that is everybody saw the
social network movie and decided since
they were under 25 they were [ __ ] CEO
of a startup it and so I mean and it
makes me sad right because there's so
many kids that I meet every day that
would have made a lot of money if they
did go to beta Mackenzie for three years
learn craft and a 20-7 would have had
great careers right now they're wasting
their time because they really aren't
number ones they don't have the stomach
for it like being an entrepreneur is a
different game like it's like there's a
level of pressure you know the one thing
I'm trying to talk more about the reason
I'm trying to talk more people out of it
is not because I want more for me
there's room for everybody it's that
we're not talking about the downside of
all the failures that are happening
there are literally people in our space
that are committing suicide there are
people in massive depression because
they failed and it's only because they
put themselves in a position to fail
because everybody just feels that if
they go to an Ivy League school and they
have rich ecosystems that they should do
their business and there's so many you
know the number seven guy and the number
13 gal at Facebook made a fuckload of
more money than anybody that's going to
start a company in the next ten years
you know so not having self awareness of
what you actually are are it and because
of the hyperbole of entrepreneurship
right now is causing a lot of people to
have limited upside and success
interesting like well we're gonna open
up to Q&A soon but you touched on
something on the aspect of storytelling
what would your advice here be
for for some of the people who are in
sales and in different functions
throughout the company what would your
advice be for them for their own
storytelling approach to reverse
engineer everything and to listen 24/7
365 I'm selling a ton of [ __ ] in a b2b
environment by following the people that
I want to sell to on social networks and
figuring out what they like in the world
besides being who they are as a
professional and reverse engineering and
exploiting their passions as a way to
sell them so in real English I mean go
follow people on Twitter and if they're
into fishing talk to them about fishing
and then sell them your SAS product you
said you said take it when you burn a
post about taking a month off I'm
selling right I'm just not doing it just
listening and everything else do right
so I talk so much that people are
confused I listen 98% of my life that's
what I do for a living I listen and it's
confusing because I'm a paradox that way
because I talk so much but it's only
after I've listened to fully I've
literally been watching everybody to the
scale of my human capabilities for three
years on their behavior on snapchat
that's why I feel like I'm ready to talk
and the b2b stuff is a [ __ ] money pit
it's amazing like I think I I have no
empathy for you guys I think it's super
easy compared to me to say I'm being
dead serious you know it stand at
[ __ ] Ogilvie or you know it's Rick at
AT&T this shouldn't be that hard and
more importantly what you have to do is
you have to eliminate romance you have
to understand what they care about more
than what you care about and that's too
common mistake of sales people like no
[ __ ] you're trying to hit your numbers
and do your thing but if you know what
the rationale is to why they're not
using you you need to exploit that you
need to figure out what that
vulnerability is and explain that to
them so I'm just reverse engineering at
scale it's why prep for zero meanings
you know zero prep I'm gonna listen like
never like I have to walk in and listen
for a little bit and then I'll know what
to do by the end you're not reading up
on them before and you're not checking
out their social accounts any of that
kind of stuff you're no not not if it's
a real pit like I mean no answer's no
later I may do some of the stuff I just
talked about of getting to know them or
if there's like I need but no no I'm not
what other mistakes just drive you crazy
you see sales people in your own office
you see marketers and other places what
just
drives you insane people are still doing
some things certain ways it's more of
that marketing in the year that you live
in you're still using lines that had a
value prop nine months ago and you've
just become a robot you've got a script
and you're like like I I said a meeting
today where one of my people didn't like
I wanted to punch him in the face like
you know just it's it's just uh it's
what they do they're just repeating or
just repeating horseshit like I just you
know people are just [ __ ] headline
readers and don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about and just repeat
the [ __ ] company line when they
already know that the person doesn't
give a [ __ ] like they're just mailing it
in you know alright cool so that's
what's it that's that's a bad
salesperson right you're just better off
going like the reason I think I'm a good
salesperson I'd rather go in and if I
can read that it's not gonna be a win
I'd rather just get out of there
I'll take my 18 minutes back and
honestly I want to be respectful to them
and as a matter of fact somebody doesn't
want to buy from you that if they see
that you're responding to that and you
get out of there and you respect their
time they probably gonna do business
with you at some point in four or ten or
fifteen years from then like to me it's
just respecting the meritocracy of the
game I respect the game business
entrepreneurship more than I care about
my own KPIs and that has allowed me to
be very successful is the goal the
eventual goal sold by the New York Jets
100% that is the goal people know about
it people do the Jets uh just know about
it yeah um you know I look I sold my
agency when I knew I was gonna grow it
substantially at a very low cost I sold
a piece of my agency to Steve Ross the
owner to the Miami Dolphins because I
wanted to get into the ecosystem and so
all my behavior maps that one KPI and
actually think that's super important
like I literally sold a company on a
nickel on the dollar because I literally
was growing it super fast I was in full
control I knew I was going to run it I
left a lot of money in the table tens of
millions of dollars of personal wealth
on the table because I know that I want
to buy the New York Jets and so when the
opportunity presented itself so when you
actually know like this is just like
let's get out of like business like if
you actually know yourself like if you
actually know what you want to happen in
your life or like how you're well
hardwired the second you make that shift
to actually reverse engineer that at all
costs including short-term losses
you win and it's hard and I don't want
to get into not practical stuff of like
your not being able to pay or student
loans or rent or upset your parents or
your spouse but [ __ ] man this you'll
only really get to do this sometime and
like playing a game that doesn't map
what you actually want it to be is a
really big mistake on that note I think
let's open it up um yeah I'll be doing
like sorry yeah we're gonna use the mic
so we can hear it in the recording if
that's okay thank you big glamorous walk
to the mic and if you guys have other
questions you'll just want to start
lining up so we can do it seamless oh
you're gonna you you can't like take the
mic and bring it to them because we're
gonna lose like four questions cuz
people are [ __ ] lazy so you guys are
seriously official right what's up
getting that's up man how's it going
what's your name our thermally a fold so
to eat to your entrepreneurship point on
your snapchat to three weeks ago you
asked for people that are you know write
in or tell you what they wanted what
their goals were you're sort of
contradicting that today saying you know
you want to get like that Bain McKinsey
feel before you just like go in and call
it quits become an entrepreneur it's
something I've been struggling with
personally yeah you and I first
interacted when I was on the Obama
campaign back in the day and I wanted
you to see some wine tastings as an
entrepreneur then I then went to finance
I went to LinkedIn and I still have
great ideas but I feel like I'm too
afraid to make a jump into being an
entrepreneur again yeah so like what
advice would you have given I feel like
I can comfortable saying this cuz we're
all about transformation what advice
would you have to like taking a step
away from your day-to-day that you love
and you really enjoy but you know your
endgame is somewhere else I think you
have to calibrate if you're a
entrepreneur or if you have
entrepreneurial tendencies and I think
this is something that's not being
talked about enough either which is to
me and I'm one guy so I don't get to say
what it is but to me the definition of
an entrepreneur you can't work at
LinkedIn ever like there was no like
there was no there was there was no I
was
gonna work somewhere right like that
like it couldn't even like rap like I
could've breathe I couldn't even do
school I became an F student because by
14 there now I'm probably all the way
over here for the more normal
conversation you know I think I think it
comes down to that conversation you're
having in your head all the time to me
I love entrepreneurship and the process
so much that I need nothing I don't need
like I would I want to sleep on the
floor with four buddies in a studio in
Hoboken because entrepreneurship is more
interesting to me than a nice watch
right I mean it I mean it's a very
simple equation you can do it you just
have to give up a lot of [ __ ] and are
you willing to and that's it and so
there's no advice there's just the
conversation you're having with yourself
and recognizing that you can have and
you know what's amazing about the
internet you can do both this didn't
exist before it's why I wrote crush it
the first book I wrote was really just
about you know 9:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the
morning you know if you're complaining
so much and you don't want to have a job
but you have to feed your family or pay
off your college loans good news
your parents didn't have this option but
all of you do go home and instead of
watching [ __ ] Breaking Bad you work
and work from 9:00 to 2:00 in the
morning for long enough until you built
something that allows you to switch I
mean it's quite practical and there's
nothing I can and you're right I do
contradict myself because it's the
advice is not forever like everything
but he's got their own advice I don't
know everybody individually if we hung
for 30 days I'd probably be able to have
a much better answer but I will say this
if you have entrepreneurial tendencies
you should always that should become
your full-time 24/7 365 hobby you know
no more bowling no more I've never been
to a happy hour in my [ __ ] life like
you know what I mean these are this is
time to do what you want to do if you
really want it on the flip side maybe
it's not like in the flip side there's a
lot of times that I wish I had more
balance in my DNA
like being on the bowling team sounds
kind of cool like like you know like
like being able to relax and not know
that everything is your fault is kind of
interests
you know when it's yours it's all your
every single problem at vaynermedia Wine
Library and Manor capital is 100% my
fault because I empower everybody else
that's [ __ ] up so there's a lot of
pressure with that I mean I don't know
if that answered it but like yeah cool
hey Gary and Jesse hey Jess um a really
specific question um I like you I like
the grind Thanks sounds crazy yeah I do
hey question is aside from revenue yes I
from traction aside from see your
business growing how do you measure it
how do you measure your grind ability
that's a good question a lot of
different ways um first I measure on
impact how many emails am I getting on a
day that are similar to that question or
the result of something I did that
impacted so like the dailyvee stuff
where dafuq is see the askgaryvee show
and the books and and taking an hour and
doing this is hopefully for one person
to get or one person hearing that answer
over there saying [ __ ] that's right you
know impact like you know you know
what's really an you know money's
awesome right and more followers and
[ __ ] metrics that's fine nothing and
I mean nothing is like getting an email
every single day of your life or two or
four that start with you changed my
[ __ ] life now when you're scared
shitless of the word guru and you don't
want to be Tony Robbins or Oprah or the
secret you're pushing and you're pushing
in the other direction too but I'd be
lying if I didn't say the most important
measuring stick I have is that for some
unknown reason through my energy and my
communication style I've been able to
break through and help people it just I
don't feel comfortable making 50 to 100
million dollars a year just being that
because I myself have cynicism around
that and so I need to identify with
myself as being an entrepreneur operator
so I need to build things but to me you
know I laughs I think digital agencies
all these digital shops they've all
become my friends
and contemporaries they would be
devastated if they realized that I was
able to build a much bigger business
than they have over they've been running
for 1215 years
I've tripled their size in four and if
they realized that I'm not spending a
hundred percent of my time doing that it
would really [ __ ] with them right you
know like to me I take enormous pride in
the operations part but I'm pumped and I
still have twenty to twenty-five percent
of my time that I'm giving back to the
overall community and I'm guilted into
it like I actually within 2000 like when
I stopped while rbtv like I kind of
wanted to walk away completely and just
build businesses and then I just kept
getting emails from crush it and they're
like the emails are intense like my
[ __ ] dad died and then this happened
and then I read watched 38 seconds of a
YouTube video and good things happen you
start getting worried that are I started
honestly saying am i selfish to the
narrative I would say don't be romantic
write about other things I was like [ __ ]
I'm being romantic to be respected as a
business man and I don't want to be this
guru thing but meanwhile the only person
that benefits is what I want the
narrative to be meanwhile all these
people like and so that's really how I
measure it am i capable of putting my
ass on two toilets of both being a
businessman and both being content that
drives results for others that's my I
know that's not you know that's my
personal way of doing it and I think
everybody's got their own version of
that right are you happy about the way
you are as a parent or do you feel good
about yourself as a citizen of the world
are you deploying enough energy against
NGOs and nonprofits what's the other
part of you even though you're grinding
24/7 that you feel good that you're
bringing to the table is how I think
about it yeah yeah
I was some intense [ __ ] right there I
know Gary this is that getting deep know
how I follow that up Gary Connor Connor
thanks for doing this pleasure when
you're looking at investing in a medium
or a new channel whether it be like
snapchat Pinterest the internet way back
when how do you measure adoption versus
perception so when do you know the
iron's hot
looking at snapchat which a lot of
people still think is like this sexting
thing college kids use most people think
right and I'm sure we could get Donald
Trump to put a LinkedIn shirt on yeah
and a lot of people would see it but it
would speak negatively because yeah
perception how do you know and judge
that and it seems like you're pretty
good so because I trust the masses over
the tastemakers right because the
LinkedIn t-shirt would get negative
responses from the authorities and the
tastemakers but maybe not from the
masses so for me being super immigrant
and quite average and pretty much
everything but this little thing that
we're focused on in this talk and just
you know just remembering where I
comfort like I don't know I feel much
closer to Sally Arkansas then I feel in
my body to any of my rich friends that
now surround me 24/7 365 it's just it's
the taste in my you know it's funny I
ran into a Clive Davis right his son was
like like came up like I met him
somewhere and we were at a Knicks game
the other day and he's like me my dad
and I was talking to him for a little
bit and I thought it was good
opportunity for me to look at somebody
who does something similar in a
different way and like it took how to
talk to him about like what does he feel
when he hears that that first time that
somebody sings and then and he knows
that they're gonna be huge right and he
couldn't really is his answer was [ __ ]
in the same way that my answer is [ __ ]
to you right now right it's I don't know
what I know is that [ __ ] I just go
now like it's literally so ridiculous
like I'm uh I'm almost embarrassed by
the lack of answer for this I pay
attention I put in my work I watch
people you know I do silly real-life
data stuff like look at the app store
and there's some yellow app at the
bottom download it like I'm a prac
Tichenor hey I'm traveling weird that
yellow app that showed up at 1:30 in the
rankings that's staying there and has it
moved out yet I've seen that yellow app
on a lot of fourteen-year-old girls at
the airport that's actually by the way
if you ever hear that I got arrested I
am NOT a creeper it's just that I'm
really all up in on teenagers phones
when I'm at the airports some dad almost
beat the [ __ ] on me the other day what
is your crime did you find anything
snapchat happened to me that way the
reason I was so early on snapchat was it
kind of popped a little bit on the
bottom of the charts and then I just cuz
luckily honestly no joke luckily it was
yellow you want to talk about something
easy to see like when people just I'm
like I'm seeing that a lot just started
digging like um but when I decide all in
like I have what snapchat it's usually
just a combination of pure math and a
lot of intuition right some things don't
scale some things you were just given
right and I feel like I really
understand people I like at the ultimate
I think I'm the ultimate salesman I
think I can I mean to get really crazy
deep the reason I'm a happy person is
because I truly think I can manipulate
anybody and the fact that I don't do bad
things with that makes me feel super at
peace with myself
seriously dude like honestly I think
that my IQ I don't even know what it is
I should probably figure it make a good
post I should probably figure out what
my IQ is because I don't know what it is
but I'm super not excited about it but I
in my will have a line that says if
humans ever figure out how to quantify
EQ I want to be dug up and tested
because I truly believe that I'm
all-time that you're that you're good at
100% true
what's up Gary hey bro how's it going
awesome um so you mentioned a little bit
about nonprofits and all that stuff I
was curious where you think social
entrepreneurship is going and just
social enterprises in general I think
it's [ __ ] right now because I think
everybody saw TOMS shoes and realized
they can make money by fronting that
they give a [ __ ] so where do you think
it's going and how can it be done yeah
it's true right yeah and we all the
reason everybody's laughing is cuz we
all know it's true like all of a sudden
after TOMS shoes did well every pitch I
saw in 2013 and I was on the board of I
was a well member of charity water and I
was I'm on the board of pencils of
promise those are fancy NGOs of the day
and so I would get pitched eight
thousand times and literally before
anything came out of their mouths like
okay listen for every umbrella we sell
we give two umbrellas to the people in
the Congo you know it's like just like
like it was just it was it was a tactic
right now as a marketing tactic right
correct
now that's why to answer your question
I'm actually quite excited about it
because now we're on the tail and it's
Esau's right it's how I think about
social networks we want completely open
for the most part with Twitter and
Facebook wasn't completely opened but it
was open then snapchat because of the
openness had an opportunity to be a
little bit more closed I actually think
the next Twitter's gonna get built in
the next five years and so I'm really
like kind of like trying to pay
attention the the space that I most was
upset about that I missed was tinder I
invested in so when Grindr got big in
the gay male community I'm like this is
a hundred percent gonna happen with guys
and girls so I invested in yo Bongo in
one in high light I chased I tried to
get into high light I chased every
single people discovery app which I knew
would mean let's hook up and so thank
God tinder was incubated I never got a
chance to invest in it but like no joke
in 2011-12 and in 213 the biggest fear
of my life was I was going to miss that
app because I knew it was going to
explode it's how I feel right now that
NGOs or social entrepreneurship I think
that somebody who comes with pure intent
and not a tactic is going to produce a
very meaningful company I'm just waiting
for that
nothing that I've seen maybe it's out
right now you know I don't see
everything but I do think that we do as
humans have enormous amounts of
compassion and we'd like to get behind
those kind of things the problem is we
know that all the hucksters came in and
used that tactic and so we kind of all
shut down from that it was kind of why I
was getting so mad back in the day on
social where people were so desperate to
get their following counts up like Haiti
haiti's earthquake was that the the
worst moment for me in marketing really
because literally even my friends people
were doing things like for every Twitter
follower I get from this tweet I'll
donate $1 to the Haiti fund
you know like that cat and I was just
like literally I'm just sitting all day
just replying like hey [ __ ] why
don't you just donate to the daily fund
like you know like are you working on
anything now that is you know socially
beneficial this is a quick - yeah sure
to meet now to me Scott Harrison from
charity water really helped me on this
makes this answer a lot more fun than it
would have been if I didn't meet him he
said we were sitting down one day and
said you know Gary I've got to really
know you're good dude he goes you're
just playing this traditionally meaning
nonprofits and doing good he's like I
can tell your plan is to just amass a
lot of wealth and your 60s and 70s and
80s you'll do all the right things and
he said why not now and it really hit me
and so for the last several years what
I've been doing is whether it is pencils
of promise or charity water or other
things that affect my family I've been
doing a ton of here's the funny thing
with me with this subject matter even
right now I'm not like Dirac I don't
want this like I'm very uncomfortable
using my good stuff as my public
conversation because so many of my
scumbucket friends use nonprofit as a
disguise to paint a picture that they're
good people so I'm trying to go the
other way I in the same way I like to
surprise people that I actually have
chops I once had somebody trolling me on
this issue okay Gary Vee [ __ ] Mark
Cuban and Jason Calacanis and Tim
Ferriss always talking about charity
stuff and tweeting like why don't you
and to the point where he just basically
say I was a bad guy I literally met him
at a Starbucks on the Upper East Side
and showed him my tax return so I what
I'm yeah I'm a little weird what he said
ya know I wanted to teach him lesson
the kid was kind of cool I was like I
showed in my tax return he was
completely blown away by my donations
and I said you're a [ __ ] idiot you're
confused by what they're doing and you
buy into that anybody can formulate the
PR story of themselves if they want to
like I'm like here's what I do
I do this and I don't talk about it I do
talk about myself as a businessman and
everybody thinks I have an e gonna sand
that and I'm like I'm fine with that
because that's business like that's what
this is winning and losing there's no
like there's no like this is real like
this is competition like people really
don't want you to win you want to win
like it's not super complicated so what
I do is I am very heavily involved with
the one thing the biggest asset my life
is my time and so what I do for Autism
Speaks and for pencils of promise and
charity water is the biggest thing I
think I could be doing and then of
course I donate for stuff I mean yeah
yes and then the other thing I've
started doing more of I did it yesterday
and felt so good start realizing I'm
giving money to certain things because
of people and doing less from my inner
circle and so I had a friend who has a
go fund me yesterday that somebody else
started for him because his car went on
fire and so I donated to that yesterday
so I'm trying to like hack what what's
the right thing to do by the ultimate
judge and jury of the universe and so I
don't do a lot of pup like the two
things I don't talk about in public is
my family like it's hard to find
pictures of my kids like all my friends
that are social media gurus love to use
their kids to [ __ ] spike up their
[ __ ] stats right I'm I think I'm
playing the absolute reverse of what so
many people think I'm doing when they
first consume me and I'm excited about
that long-term narrative yeah right I
think we have time for one more is that
yeah we got much - yeah cool great yeah
I'm like three more I know it's 4:30
like 4:30 have to be downstairs right
[ __ ] bang ow [ __ ] tonight's and 15
nice all right all right great um so
this is a very basic question which
writing Brenna Brennan's meet you nice
to meet you uh so I found myself
pretending like I knew a lot of the
companies you mentioned okay um so I'm
wondering what's the best way to stay
informed I know you said you're a
practitioner
and you're constantly referencing like
observing other people but how do you
stay informed of startups or just just
the whole ecosystem media and I'm in a
weird spot in my career now because so
much of its coming to me so you know one
of the great things and one of the
reasons I decided to build my personal
brand the reason I built the personal
brand was because I need the admiration
the cuddling and all that but to was you
start reversing it and it comes to you
so I have a lot of stuff coming to me
but there are a lot of tactics ice time
this is boring but I'll say for a fifth
time the top 150 free apps in the App
Store in Apple is a very easy way you
see things pop up you're like what's yet
Yaak you download it you play with it
you now know what it is there's
producthunt
which i think is a great utility if you
want to know about that and then I still
think what LinkedIn influencers do and
what Twitter does well for what you know
there are clearly tastemakers who can be
the DJ's for you I think really taking a
step back and deciding the twenty six
five nine people that you want to follow
that are actually in the business to
keep people informed with whatever you
care about is quite me I mean the [ __ ] I
give away for free is ludicrous
seriously I'm giving away my best advice
for free every day because I feel like
that's the best way to attract
opportunity not to hold it back and sell
it in a mastermind class or an e-book or
at vaynermedia even so I would say
there's plenty people like me in
different genres find those people
follow them and let them be the DJs of
all that noise for Jason Hirschhorn
email list is incredible he's also an
influencer he writes I rep he's amazing
I think he's super interesting
I think there's 25 to 50 DJs I'm
assuming I don't I know Jason's one that
I believe in that are out there that can
really really help you and cut out the
noise trim it whatever lists or
subscriptions you're in find those
people for whatever you're trying to
achieve it's very very very possible to
achieve yeah you're welcome
they're coming up
there's got to be more people in the
audience that have question you make
blood circulation it's good to get up so
I'm gonna ask this one and then you guys
will have a minute to come ask a few
more so this one's coming from the
stream the question is by the way the
Downs the Dow is down 254 points I just
want to make a random statement this is
just ad hoc side note I'm so [ __ ]
pumped I want the economy to completely
melt because well what I'll tell you why
because back to the fake entrepreneurs
things the amount of [ __ ] businesses
that are raising money that have nothing
I hate when the economy is great because
B and C and B players get to live a
player lives
I want meritocracy I want this I'm
pumped and I'm going to lose a fuckload
of money I'm sitting on so much paper
money on snapchat Pinterest ubers like
life-changing like all my feet like I'll
lose a shitload of money that's how much
I love meritocracy these down rounds
from fidelity and everything like no
worries you like this nothing worries me
not when it comes to business sorry
and we're back alright the question from
the stream gary is who is a better
dinner conversation tim ferriss or kevin
rose that's a good question um for me
it's Tim Ferriss because I love how I
just answer it um super didn't dodge
that so I'm much friendlier with Kevin
rose and and feel much more kinship to
Kevin Kevin really put me on like I feel
like Kevin was like dr. Dre and I was
like Snoopy like put like Digg nation's
changed my career that video blog
the reason Tim's more interesting for me
is Kevin and I are so similar we have a
lot of the same beliefs and so that's a
fun conversation to just you know ego it
out for two hours and just go back and
forth and say how awesome we are Tim's
on some different [ __ ] Tim's like LSD is
good and like you know like it Tim's
just in outer space in a place where I'm
not and he's super different than I am
and and and super similar I would say
we're 80% similar but the 20% is
massively interesting he's thinking
about things at a heavier level than I
am
he just is and some of those things are
right and so I feel like learn more from
Tim because our brains are different not
that I feel like plenty of people learn
more from
than Tim and vice-versa it just depends
on how you're wired so for me the more
interesting date is really Tim because
he's gonna be like dude there's this new
thing like if you take baby oil and this
rock from Cambodia and you do this and
he shave it on your head you'll live
forever I'm like really okay you know
like like he's into that kind of [ __ ]
which I find interesting thank you and
somebody else get up and ask something
like this like is it I mean never see
you again in real life
never again um hi I'm Donna hey Donna um
so I actually started my career in PR
and back then it was like the cool thing
to do everyone now it sure and now it
doesn't exist and everyone wants to work
in digital agencies so um as someone who
has a digital agency what do you think
is sort of gonna be like the next wave
of that and where do you think um the
concept of PR is sort of going so I
think I think this thing stays LLL
evolve and I'll probably be VR 15 years
from now that disrupts it but here's why
PR got disturbed by this it was just
that PR is b2b you know PR when it was
cool and its heyday was b2b you had a
rolodex you could influence the Today
Show or the New York Times and what the
internet did was commoditized
storytelling and information and so now
we're all in play we all tomorrow can be
that and so became the world of selling
through stories became much more c2c
than it became b2b and that's why PR got
disrupted so I think the thing that
happens next is when the platform of
attention shifts and I think the only
thing in sight is VR and how will that
work and what are going to be the rules
of that world and does is there one is
is this Facebook win and oculus controls
all our contact lenses or Google and
then they get to be the first page we
see and they go back to b2b behavior
versus see so I don't I don't think I
don't think there'll be a change right
now because so many voices can carry so
much weight I think of it as remember
when everybody said that a you know your
15 minutes of fame now I think of it as
everybody's famous to 15 people and I
think that shift is
a big one I think that her PR hey Gary
David
you got me to do something on Sunday
that I thought I never would do I joined
periscope you were tweeting from the
Superbowl and I thought it was like it
was awesome
it's cool right yeah it was it was like
I can't believe this happened or even I
was like I thought I was gonna get
arrested I got on the field somehow
through David Levy the president Turner
somehow finagle my way on the field of
the Super Bowl and then I go on
periscope and Facebook live and it was
just crazy and the amount of fun you
brought that up and this is what I do I
do things and then I listen and so
watching how many people like holy crap
like I'm really not watching the pregame
show I'm watching Gary Vee stream
because it's more access right it was
more real and it was just like you know
we like that stuff I felt like I was at
the Super Bowl
I was like on the field and I get to see
what everyone's talking about it was
crazy you were passing the phone around
to all your friends and other like it
was great yeah I was like coming I'm
there um thanks brother
I wanted to click my shoes so yeah who
do you rely on like for mentors or seek
advice or is it all self manifested this
questions tough because this is the one
I think most puts me in that ego place
that I'm always scared to be in because
I'm in it to begin with I outside of my
dad early on teaching me that which is
really where I didn't go and become a
huckster at mastermind and really went
to my word is bond my legacy matters I
want to be good like he really helped me
cuz I was cuz the reason I am what I am
is I have all that [ __ ] in me
besides that piece of advice and that
moment I've been weird I've read like
six books like I know nothing about all
these other influencers outside of if I
know them like really I don't even know
how they like I get into some weird
things where people like bring up very
famous people and I say things like
who's that like really inappropriate
things like because I'm super
undereducated on some of this stuff I'm
so in my own [ __ ] it's so I mean I
didn't even know this is not a joke what
I'm about to tell you in 2006 when I was
31 years old I didn't even know agency
these were a thing because the way I
built wine library I did it all myself
direct to the platforms that I was using
I didn't even know that Madison Avenue
advertising agencies existed somebody
came to sell me billboards if you lived
in New Jersey and during that time I
just have billboards of myself up and
talked about in our society there was
billboards of me saying watch the Wine
Library TV show because I literally used
to drive from New York to New Jersey I'm
like hey you know like and when the guy
sold him to me
I did the creative I gave it back to him
and then he gave me a bill and I lost my
[ __ ] because I didn't know I thought he
worked for CBS Viacom but he had some
lope
you know Lopez like mediate like he was
a media agency who was charging him like
for what like you know like like I
literally didn't even know there that
ecosystem and the truth is my under
education my lack of education my lack
of that has hurt me because I had a
pattern recognized later my life it's
why I'm gonna win later in my life the
reason I'm not gonna buy the Jets in my
40s and I'm gonna buy him in my 70s is
because I didn't I didn't know when I
put all my personal post tax money into
Twitter and Facebook
this is satisfy I'm now 35 I didn't know
that I could go to other human beings
and raise money and take 20% of the
upside if I did I'd already be a
billionaire because I would have bet my
life on Facebook so like just think
about that just basic something you
could read when you're 11 years old on
the Internet of like carrying money like
basic fun dynamics was something I
didn't know at 35 years old because if I
did I would have raised it made a lot of
people in my world of time a lot of
money and I would have made 20% the
upside which would have been remarkable
so you know I don't when I say I don't
have mentors I think of that as a
weakness but I just know it's my truth
and it's all I got and I'm so Slyke
meditation meditation is about to
explode in America right like like what
happened with Starbucks and coffee shops
and what happened with SoulCycle and
exercising is one thousand one thousand
percent can happen with meditation in
four and a half five years everybody
here is gonna go to the [ __ ]
meditation thing and they're gonna have
their [ __ ] t-shirt so we're all gonna
sit there and it's gonna be at scale
it's a trillion dollar business why does
it why because I paid
consumer trends because they had space
because of the couple of studios in New
York in LA because I just know how [ __ ]
works and the only reason I'm telling
you this story right now is to get it on
film so we can do the recall in four
years would be like I told you and so so
if you want to know why I'm telling you
this story but oh I was trying to figure
out why did I get here besides that I
will never do it I'm so happy and so
grateful for the way I'm hardwired and
soft wired that I'm literally scared to
do meditation cuz I'm scared in my
triggers something in my brain in a
different direction and make me not this
100% complete happy and it's the same
reason that I have mentors I know what
I'm doing it's good for me I like it I
don't even want to be affected by other
people I don't want to hear from any
[ __ ] guru I want to watch what you
guys do it's scale and make my decisions
and just do my thing okay yeah let's do
it
thought that was a pretty good way to
end but okay that was good okay like
it's not gonna be a storybook go ahead
d-roc can you believe this today we've
had a very weird day
like this has come up like four times
today I don't
it happened because I've been snapping
my like I did it yesterday I went to a
from LA meetings to San Diego speech to
redeye to Miami to New York to meetings
late last night so it's come up because
of my last 24 hours on snap I think um
not really you know you know like once
like four times a year
like I like collapse and go to sleep at
like 7:00 p.m. and I'll need like a hard
core like 15 hour sleep but and I
started taking care of my health about
two years ago 18 months ago and I was
not I mean I don't think I've picked up
any more energy when I was 25 pounds
heavier and eating like [ __ ] and not
exercising I just have so much a natural
adrenaline I showed up to somebody's
podcast yesterday and he was Facebook
liveing and I went back and read all the
comments last night at midnight because
I don't get tired and literally
everybody's like this guy's on [ __ ]
drugs which is really interesting for LA
and they meant it cuz they don't know
who I was like they're like like why do
all these guys have to take drugs to
like and I was like [ __ ] I've never even
tried a cigarette I've never done
anything in my life I'm like I've been
left out from all that good
[ __ ] and people still think it because I
just had it's just natural DNA I truly
think it's the same way as being pretty
or six-foot-five it's just something you
were given and like I like it I'm glad I
like that I can I truly truly I really
believe what I'm about to say and this
is hyperbolized to the moon I truly
think I'm the hardest-working person on
earth I truly believe that I just work
18 hours a day every day like I just do
cool is it awesome
Gary Vader thanks guys all right Gary
chip thank you both so much
LinkedIn thank you please thank them
again for their incredible time